the invisible man starring elizabeth
moss was the last film that many saw in
theaters before the covet shutdowns
or one of the first they saw at home
right after what many don't know
is that the character of the invisible
man came from the very first
interconnected cinematic universe
established
way back in the 1930s the universal
monsters
the universal monster movies were some
of the first sequels ever made in
hollywood
and as they introduced more characters
eventually those characters crossed
paths in other movies
flash forward to 2020 when the invisible
man became the first of many low-budget
horror movies that blumhouse productions
is making to add contemporary teeth to
these classic tales
so sit back for a history of the monster
movies and a little intel on what's
coming next for this monster partnership
in 1931 dracula became the first
universal monster taki
i am dracula those words were spoken by
bella lugosi
and though bram stoker's count was
lugosi's most famous character universal
used different actors for three films in
the 40s
lon chaney jr and john carradine but
much more on cheney later
that's my conversation a guy growls like
a wolf kiradine played the transylvanian
bloodsucker in dracula's first crossover
films first in house of frankenstein in
1944
and then in house of dracula in 1945
each film featured both frankenstein's
monster
and count dracula but it was lugosi's
dracula who met abbott and costello in
1948
the first of a series of films where a
monster meets abbott and costello
and comedy ensues yes meats
not verses oh the stakes in a crossover
movie were so different back then
count dracula sleeps in this coffin but
rises every night at sunset
chick is right this is awful silly stuff
it'd be 31 years before universal would
raise their iconic character from his
coffin again
frank langella played the seductive and
sinister vampire in 1979's dracula
langella was called the sexiest vampire
to nibble on screen
which perhaps explains the more
seductive vampire stories that would
emerge afterwards
back to the original 1931 dracula this
didn't just introduce the world to
horror icon bella lugosi
but also to the character of scientist
vampire hunter van
helsing edward van sloane who played
helsing would reprise the slayer in the
dracula list sequel
dracula's daughter in 1936.
in the next century universal attempted
to create a franchise for hugh jackman
in the role in 2004
with richard roxburgh playing dracula
though that potential franchise starter
stalled the character did get his own tv
series
which has aired since 2016 on sci-fi
why is it so important to kill this
dracula anyway because he's the son of
the devil
i mean besides that dracula himself
would get his own 21st century reboot in
dracula
untold an origin tale for vlad the
impaler that made the vampire more of a
warrior than previous versions
this film was released in a cycle of
universal monster movies released in the
arts that focused more on
action than horror with the successful
partnership between universal and
blumhouse on the cheaper and more
grounded
invisible man dracula is already set to
get a new makeover from jennifer boddy's
director karen kusima who will bring the
classic character into our modern world
i'd be careful finding virgin blood vlad
with the deepest malice we deliver this
virgin
unto thee
released in the same year as dracula
james wales frankenstein used the stage
adaptation of mary shelley's classic
book for the basis of its film
the same approach that universal had
done for dracula to ease the adaptation
process and start filming
right away lugosi actually filmed tests
as the monster right after filming
dracula on the very same set
lugosi eventually turned down the role
because it didn't have enough dialogue
enter boris karloff karloff was the
iconic performance of frankenstein's
monster
and karloff played the role three times
between 1931
and 1939
but it was actor glenn strange who
played frankenstein in all the crossover
films
opposite dracula and abbott and costello
in between turning down the chance to
play frankenstein's monster
and then later playing him and
frankenstein meets the wolf man
lugosi played the hunchback blacksmith
igor in
two frankenstein films son of
frankenstein and the
ghost of frankenstein as igor he not
only got to rise from the dead
but he did get more lines than the
monster
they die dead i
die live the hunchback's lab
assistant that many parody films such as
young frankenstein would dub
igor was actually named fritz in the
1931 frankenstein
and did not appear in the novel but was
created for the first play adaptation
in the original film karloff isn't
listed in the opening credits as playing
the monster
instead a question mark stands in its
place a callback to the way the actor
who played the monster was credited in
the playbill for the first frankenstein
stage production
in 1823
i know what it feels like to be god
similar to dracula frankenstein would
have numerous hammer films made in
britain in the 1950s through the 1970s
and though there were a handful of new
frankenstein films in the 21st century
the classic universal monster hasn't
been featured in a universal property
since meeting abbott and costello in
1948
however universal is currently sitting
on numerous potential frankenstein
movies
one is a potential adaptation from
producer james wan
concerning neighborhood kids who
discover that their neighbor is
attempting to build a human in his
basement
and both john krasinski and angelina
jolie have attempted to get a version of
the bride of frankenstein off the lab
table
which no doubt would feature the bride
more than the mere five minutes that
elsa lane chester
created one of horror's most iconic
characters in
[Music]
after the opening of king tut's tomb in
1922 universal hoped to purchase an
existing work about an ancient mummy's
curse
however one to the studio's liking
wasn't found and thus
1932's the mummy became the first
original universal monster movie
boris karloff played imotep and though
he was credited as a question mark in
frankenstein
he became an overnight sensation and
thus the following year his credit for
his next monster movie
was an all caps karloff despite being a
success this mummy had no direct sequels
the only such film from the classic 30s
introductory movies to do so
still there were five universal movies
that featured a different
egyptian mummy carus who was played four
times
by once again lon chaney jr
it was the carus mummy that met abbott
and costello
which was the final abbott and costello
meets such and such
monster movie so that was a wrap on two
universal franchises
emo tepe wouldn't rise again until
brendan fraser and rachel weiss came
knocking on his tomb in 1999
steven summer's indiana jones style
action comedy mystical hybrid
was the first universal monster remake
in two decades
the frasier vice lead movies were so
successful they spawned a trilogy of new
films including a spin-off the scorpion
king
and an animated television series the
introduction to the scorpion king in
2001's the mummy returns
marked the acting debut of dwayne the
rock johnson
and his standalone spin-off movie in
2002 became the former wrestler's first
leading role
all told this cycle of films from 1999
to 2008 made
1.4 billion at the worldwide box office
with that coin it's no wonder universal
went back to the mummy when trying to
launch a new interconnected monster
universe
however the tom cruise action vehicle
went up against wonder woman
a beloved character who hadn't yet had
her own mega movie let alone a reboot
and the movie that was supposed to
launch a new interconnected universe of
films failed on its first announced try
goodbye russell crows jekyll and hyde
javier bardem's frankenstein monster and
johnny depp's invisible man
it was a different version of the
invisible man that was made on a tiny 7
million
budget that would reset the course of
the modern universal monster movies
but more on that in a minute let's again
travel back to the 1930s
claude raines received the role of the
invisible man at the insistence of the
director james whale
because reign's voice was so distinct
which was the most important part of his
performance wrote it on yourselves
everything would have come right if you
only left me alone based on the hg wells
novel the 1933 film was a pioneer of
many practical effects
when the invisible man was completely
invisible wires were pulled to knock
over
items when he had some articles of
clothing on but was otherwise invisible
this effect was achieved by having
reigns wear a black velvet suit
and perform against a black backdrop
then the backdrop would be filmed
naturally and the shots were combined
using a matte process
and yes he met abbott and costello too
more than
60 years after meeting abbott and
costello johnny depp would be announced
to play the invisible man
though after tom cruise's mummy that
film remained invisible
however in 2019 universal announced it
would team up with blumhouse productions
producers of inexpensive but provocative
horror films such as get out and the
purge to field director and character
driven pitches on reinventing monster
stories from their back catalog
the first to go into production was lee
1l's invisible man
this invisible man was told from the
point of view of his victim played by
elizabeth moss
in a timely tale about domestic violence
and victims testimonies going unchecked
by police
making four times its budget back on its
opening weekend alone the invisible man
was
the last success at the box office
before covet 19
caused theaters to temporarily shut down
there's a sequel planned on the hit 2020
film and also a separate film from
elizabeth banks
the invisible woman which the pitch
perfect 2 director pitched after pulling
from universal's character vaults
lon chaney's father played the very
first universal monster in the silent
film the phantom of the opera
and lon chaney jr played not just the
wolf man but also frankenstein's monster
the mummy and dracula so the cheney men
played five of the original seven
classic monsters
universal however credited jr in the
first monster movies including the wolf
man with his
father's name lon chaney even though his
father had passed away in 1930.
the look of the wolfman was actually
created by jack pierce for a previous
universal werewolf movie
1935's werewolf of london but the star
of the film
howard hall didn't approve because he
was too unrecognizable in the makeup
and so it went unused cheney however
preferred the look and the rest is
history
the wolfman screenwriter kurt siedmak
created the lore of the silver bullet
being
what could stop a werewolf his
inspiration was hearing the term silver
bullet in a lone ranger radio program
and he just liked the sound of it siad
mack also wrote the quote-unquote
ancient poem about werewolves that
features in the 1941
film and the 2010 remake benicio del
toro portrayed the wolf man in the 2010
film though it wasn't his first
appearance in human canine makeup
as his first movie role was duke the
dogface boy
and peewee herman's big top peewee the
effects heavy film did not earn back its
budget but it did set the template of
how monster movies would be made in that
decade
heavy on effects and action the wolfman
is next in line to get the blumhouse
remake treatment however with a modern
setting and low budget from the director
of the invisible man
lee 1l ryan gosling is set to howl at
the moon for 1l
but the actor will do more than dawn
makeup as the story pitch for the remake
came from him he doesn't tell me what to
do he just
told you i know he i let him
the last monster introduced during the
classic universal monster years was the
creature from the black lagoon
the project actually originated at a
citizen
cane dinner party
no the creature isn't named rosebud but
an actor in the film
william hollande was told the story of a
half man half reptile
that haunted the amazon river at an
orson welles dinner party
more than a decade later hollande was
producing the creature from the black
lagoon based on that conversation
the creature design actually came from
an oscar statuette as the director jack
arnold had recently been nominated for
an
oscar for best documentary and looked at
his certificate and added gills and
webbed hands
and decided that that was the creature
the creature's final brush with prestige
was
oscar again except this time it was
missed guillermo del toro pitched his
auteur take on reviving the creature
from the black lagoon to universal but
the studio passed
that original pitch was retooled and
eventually became the best picture
winning
the shape of water scarlett johansson
was rumored to be cast in a reboot back
in 2015
though nothing ever materialized with
universal and blumhouse taking pitches
from many directors on their monster
movies
a return to the amazon could be booked
at some point or did del toro's oscar
win push creature
further down the river what's your
favorite classic universal monster
and which remake are you looking forward
to the most let us know
in the comments below
[Music]
you